I am pleased to welcome to the platform
mr. Daniel s golden administrator of the
National Aeronautics and Space
Administration mr. golden will now give
the address
president vest members of the board of
trustees administration and faculty
distinguished guests friends and loving
families and most of all the MIT class
of 2001 I am deeply honored to be here
and it is a tremendous privilege to be
addressing you today when I received
this invitation I immediately told my
wife Judy about it
she has an extremely tough job which she
happens to do very well my wife's the
one who on occasion has to bring the
nasa chief back to earth she kind of
shook her head she told me that mi t--'s
past commencement speakers have been
some of the world's most powerful people
and then she asked do you really think
you could compete with the president the
United States the UN Secretary General
click and clack the guys from car Talk
probably not but I do have one thing
going for me I might not be on the radio
every Saturday morning but I am a rocket
scientist and if that's not enough I
told my wife you know NASA is famous for
fitting a square peg in a round hole
well at MIT those outstanding
technologists somehow managed to
precariously balanced an eight-foot
anvil wearing 48 units on top of the
great dome I said don't worry honey
these are my people I'd like to start
today by telling you a little about the
robe I'm wearing exactly one year ago
today I was invited to give a lecture at
the University of Padua in Italy after
receiving an honorary Doctorate the
University of Padua is where one of my
heroes prefer a professor by the name of
Galileo Galilei built his first
telescope it was where Galileo made so
many celestial discoveries and it was
where he wrote Siderius nuncius starry
messenger his book detailing the
satellites of Jupiter and the
composition of the Milky Way the
University of Padua in fact in the very
same room I was so incredibly humbled to
speak in is where Galileo delivered
countless lectures to some of the best
and the brightest students in the world
of course if Galileo will alive today
and wanted to speak to the best and the
brightest there's really no doubt he'd
come right here to the Charles River and
MIT
it might be hard to lure him from his
country of birth ooh I lost myself I'm
so excited a hi-tech a hi-tech president
it might be hard to lure him from the
country of his birth but I think
president vest could do it if the offer
was sweet enough you'd have to promise
Galileo he would never have to recant
his teachings and of course president
vest you'd have to give him tenure the
robe on wearing today is what I wore at
Padua that day it is the garb that
lecturers have worn at Padua since
Galileo's time actually they had to wear
this robe and this cap
contrary to what many you are thinking
I'm not wearing this because I lost some
cruel bet I'm not wearing it because I'm
the victim of the latest MIT hack at
least not yet
I wear this cap and gown because I want
to give you a visual image as you lift
off from this wonderful institution to
explore and discover whatever mysteries
of life may hold you may not remember me
but perhaps you remember the cap and
gown more than that I hope that each and
every one of you remembers Galileo not
necessarily his lectures but his lessons
and his life for his grand as all of
Galileo's discoveries and contributions
were I think his example what motivated
him to live his life the way he did was
really quite simple he was committed to
lifelong learning he settled for nothing
less than excellence
he not only sought truth Galileo
believed more than anything else that he
would find it
I say these I say that these are simple
notions
I do not want to imply that they're easy
like Galileo you must have imagination
the ingenuity and sometimes the audacity
necessary to live your life in this
fashion you must also realize that the
stuff of excellence truth real
scientific truth can be elusive
not just in Galileo's time but also in
our own time as well it is too often
covered by the heavy fog of fear and
hidden it hidden by the darkness of your
detractors you must believe in yourself
you must have the desire you must have
the focus to see truth clearly that the
winner of the harvard-yale game every
year is MIT tells me that you have the
imagination and the ingenuity thing
covered and that MIT students once made
their president's office disappear says
you have audacity to spare as for the
second part of the equation consider it
a personal challenge never to let your
commitment to learning be denied to
strive for excellence to believe in
yourself and have the ability to
prioritize and focus because if you meet
that challenge and I know MIT grads can
and I know MIT grads will you will be
responsible for perhaps the most
dramatic revolution in the history of
humankind it is a revolution that will
even surpass the one that started when
Galileo himself firm Kant first came to
cast his gaze skyward I believe that
with all my heart think about this over
the last 50 years we have been witness
to so many incredible achievements from
jet travel to space travel from TV to
mp3 even from instant coffee to instant
messaging these discoveries and
inventions have changed not only the
view of our planet and our universe but
our place in it your contributions can
blow all the others away but only if you
begin by asking a straightforward
question I'll even use today's
vernacular what have you done for me
lately our aircraft have improved
dramatically since the introduction of
the revolutionary Boeing 707 first
introduced 40 years ago today the planes
instruments have a few more computer
chips and a few more lines of code but
basically we're flying the same types of
planes in the same airspace at the same
speeds there's just more of them to
burden the system we have not had a
revolutionary change in the automotive
industry almost since its inception we
still cut in grind materials just as we
always have
and 32 years after the eagle has landed
we're still using virtually the same
technology to keep our Rockets flying
even the information technology we're so
rightfully proud of the kind of systems
that make it possible for MIT to show
the world the value of education by
putting its cost materials online and
available for free even those systems
are approaching the physical conceptual
and economic limits today's computers
they calculate they don't think or
reason information systems are hard
deterministic not soft and adaptive with
your commitment to learning with your
desire for excellence with your belief
in yourself and your search for truth
all of that's going to change in the
next half century in the next 50 years
you will usher in the Nano revolution
and discover what is possible as we
approach technology from information
systems to materials at the atomic scale
you will employ what I call biomimetics
that's when we replace traditional
technology by mimicking biology or
making hybrid systems that integrate
biologically the biology directly
computers will behave more like the
human brain airplane wings will adapt to
different flight conditions much like a
bird's wings adapt now systems will be
self sensing and self-correcting for you
the silicon based computer chip will
belong in a museum next to the dinosaurs
what will all this mean if excellence
and truth are your goals will
the things that Galileo could only dream
about you will cure today's diseases and
allow people to live to the limits of
the bodies they were born with you will
solve global climate change and make
sustainable development a reality you
will enable you will send probes beyond
our solar system and the stars you may
look up with an answer a question as old
as humankind itself are we alone and you
will make my dream come true
not in 50 years but in the next 10 to 20
a spacecraft will land the hatch will
open a ladder will drop then the world
will watch as an astronaut in a white
suit with an American flag on the
shoulder steps down and crunches her
boot on the dusty red surface of Mars
are these goals lofty the dreams big the
missions risky you bet and the chances
are that you will meet your share of
detractors and no doubt you will
encounter some failure along the way but
remember that Galileo was put under
house arrest for his beliefs people
thought he was a heretic certainly if
you take risk and come up short
it probably won't compare to that don't
be afraid get up dust yourself off and
move on I'll tell you what I tell the
NASA employees after we have a failure
that's usually witnessed by billions of
people not experiencing any failure in
life is rarely a sign of perfection
rather it's a sign that your goals are
not bold enough systems can be replaced
the science isn't being denied just
delayed failure is not an option
only if you try to avoid it and refuse
to learn from it
the real mark of your character comes
from not how you react to your successes
of which I know there will be many but
how you react to failures of which if
you're bold there will be a number in
your
lifetime so always believe in yourself
and remain committed to learning to
excellence the truth that is the lesson
of Galileo it is also a lesson I learned
from my father he would so be so proud
to see me standing here today he always
spoke fondly of MIT he would probably
ask hey Dan what's with the outfit but
he'd be proud nonetheless my father died
about six years ago
it was right around the time we
discovered what we call the Mars Rock
it's still controversial but many
believe the rock contains fossilized
bacteria that originated on Mars and
thus proof of life the great debate goes
on I remember clearly to the day when
three scientists from Houston came into
my office and briefed me on their
findings could you imagine being in
charge of NASA and having people come
into your office and say we think we've
discovered fossilized life from Mars it
doesn't get any better than that I
couldn't believe it I was overwhelmed I
asked every possible question I could
think of my personal acquisition of
these people lasted for hours and when
they left I was convinced we should
announce the find however controversial
it would be I felt worldwide peer review
was not only good for science but it was
good for young people to witness the
scientific process and the intense
debate that would go on and it still
goes on that night I couldn't control my
excitement I had to share the discovery
with the man who brought me to the
Hayden Planetarium when I was a young
boy and introduced me to what became my
personal life passion I called my father
in the hospital my father graduated from
college with a biology degree during the
Great Depression brilliant career choice
he couldn't get a job for years he
worked in the post office and ultimately
became a teacher a Korea he passionately
loved even though he was weak and dying
of cancer
we spoke for over an hour he was just
excited as I was he absorbed everything
and asked more questions than I did and
I even pretended dad I know all the
answers at the end of the call I said
dad you have to do me a favor you can't
tell anybody about this for weeks at
least it's top secret right now my
father replied an Who am I gonna tell
get a grip I'm in the hospital dying of
cancer well about a month later we made
the announcement my father passed away
within days I can't help but believe
what kept my father alive until that
announcement was made in large part was
his lifelong commitment to learning he
always sought truth in he had an
irrepressible desire to see his only son
do the same that somehow I could play
I'll be at a small role in attempting to
solve one of the mysteries of life
literally gave my father more life
that's the power truth and learning and
excellence the search for what it is
that ignites the human spirit overcoming
the unexpected and discovering the
unknown that's what life is all about
that's really what Galileo saw when he
looked through his telescope and that is
what awaits you the cliche goes that you
are the future I contend the future is
now so with imagination ingenuity and
audacity explore discover change the
world and have fun while you're at it
always take out time to love and to live
you're going to be busy but never forget
family and friends and in the words and
in other words as a parent on behalf of
all those parents who are here today
please at least once in a while don't
forget to forget to check in with the
old Mission Control as you blaze into
the heavens indulge us I mentioned
earlier that of Galileo were alive today
he'd want to teach here in a way Galileo
is here today
in truth there are 2400 galileo's
sitting right in front of me about to
get their well-earned degrees MIT class
of 2001 with a confidence that you will
never ever have to recant your
discoveries remain committed to learning
set off less nothing for nothing less
than excellence do not only seek truth
but believe in yourself
that way you will find truth
congratulations and Godspeed
to all of you
[Applause]